you know they let you choose your own
theme music I don't they told you that
they wanted the cranberries originally
but I kind of talked them out of that so
we're talking about disruption today
there's a lot of hype another way to say
hype is around social media so
as we talk about disruption we're gonna
talk about how is social media
disrupting marketing and what is its
role in consumer behavior and so what
I'm gonna do is walk you guys through a
series of myths possible misperceptions
I've called a lot of this from Twitter
and at the end we're gonna try to
squeeze in a few questions because I
know that there's a lot of interest in
what's happening around social media but
the first myth that we're going to talk
about today is is social media
technology we think about twitter and
dick was here earlier and Facebook and
YouTube and we think about why this is a
major technology company and we would
sort of argue the opposite which is
technology or social media is actually
biology and consumer behavior and we
never elevate the technological channel
over the consumer behavior which is
social is all about social media is
actually physiologically changing our
brains right now all of you out there
are taking on addictive characteristics
when we check our text when we check our
Facebook our email dopamine is being
released in your brain the more
repetitively do it it's the same process
that an addict goes through and what's
really interesting about that is we've
maybe always underestimated how inherent
and innate social behavior is in all of
us for a lot of people social isn't an
end we don't do social to get something
or to do something we are social because
we are social not coincidentally there's
been recent studies that have come out
that have talked about how lonely we are
in this world and it's what's when you
don't have that dopamine firing right as
they said I think was the
spinors what codons up must come down
when you don't have that dopamine fine
you feel lonelier and secondarily to
that not coincidentally for the first
time in history there are more people
living inside cities than outside
so this social behavior is innate and
both a means and an end so where does
this leave us as marketers and brands
it's really simple we need to be human
we need to relate to our customers and
our prospects and our consumers at a
really personal level and I would ask
you with a show of hands who here thinks
that addiction and loneliness are a good
fertile soil for what marketers need to
do so it's not all bad on that front but
we do need to understand that social has
been this massive shift in behavior and
not think of it so much in terms of
Technology ok now this one I'm gonna
show you guys a magazine cover this is
wired and this is marki Andreessen who
spoke today about social bubbles I think
so did dick from Twitter and when asked
if there was a social media Mark said no
and Dick said I don't really pay
attention then but what I'm gonna tell
you is social media is absolutely a
bubble if you're a stock analyst you
look at because ok
I bought a a an apartment in New York
City in 2005 so I'm a quasi expert in
what bubbles look like but you look at I
mean inflated valuations and if you
follow p/e ratios at all you understand
that a billion dollars for Instagram or
some of these companies is not really
looking it's classical p/e investment
you're also looking for at a glut of
competitors if you're trying to hire
someone right now in social and digital
they're about 40% of love market in
terms of what they are and the last
thing would cause a snakes on a plane
syndrome if anyone seen the Samuel
Jackson genius masterpiece uber had a
tremendous amount of hype and then when
people want to use it right there I have
the word of mouth not so great we see a
lot of that in social media so where
does that leave us well that leaves us
you guys may want to make
really discerning financial investments
about whether you invest in Facebook but
as marketers this is from Mark
Zuckerberg it shows how content is being
the amount of content we share is
doubling every two years social behavior
is incredibly ingrained it's hard for us
not to go back to the year 2000 when
the.com bubble burst now did we as users
accelerate our usage of websites that
have become part of everything that we
do all of our marketing absolutely we're
seeing the same inherent value being
created in social media we see that
mostly through social sharing social
media or web to point if you want to use
it it's precedent simply means the user
is in control of the media and when I
think of Facebook Twitter and YouTube if
it hadn't been them it would have been
someone else because media doesn't drive
the consumer behavior it's reflective of
the consumer behavior and we always need
to remember that and that's why social
media and that social behavior is gonna
alter the marketing landscape for the
next 15 years well financially we would
sort of argue that it is indeed a bubble
so where has left us in a practical
standpoint is whenever we do marketing
we have three criteria why engage which
we've always asked in advertising and
marketing why this brand because social
and all good digital marketing matters
directly to the brand promise the new
one is why share if you want to know
whether you've created compelling
original content or a good experience
the amount of people that share that
content is actually one of the best
indicators of how your marketing is
performing so this sits the top of
everything that we do in marketing today
why share why would someone pass this on
to somebody okay
raise of hands if you're at all involved
in marketing is your job harder as a
result of social media let's see a show
of hands all of a sudden you woke up and
you've got a whole new set of jobs
you've got the
ability there's millions of
conversations taking place your brand is
being discussed and so there's no
question in this myth that marketing's
got more difficult but let's truly
understand the DNA of why it did and
we'll think about this in classic supply
and demand terms the supply of consumer
attention the amount of attention we can
give to marketing to media is relatively
fixed I didn't put fix there because we
haven't gotten to the point where we've
saturated our attention but we know that
demand is growing exponentially the most
dominant trend in all of marketing today
is the consumers perception that they
are busier than ever and that there is
more competition for their media
practically what's happening is all
consumers are spending more time
consuming media for shorter periods of
time if you're a digital native like me
who grew up with digital and social
media if you give me an hour of free
time I will look at 27 different pieces
of media it's gonna have implications
for the customer journey the path to
purchase that is pretty fundamental and
so where does that leave us if you're
gonna disrupt in the marketplace you
still have to understand something
that's pretty cool booyah which is
you've got to satisfy the basic needs
goodwill breeds goodwill 70% of
everything that's happening in social
media related to a company or brand
falls under four categories utility they
want information entertainment they want
you to an outlet someone earlier was
talking about that time wasting value
the number one reason someone joins a
Facebook page is they want something
financial they want something in
incentive from you and last they want
reciprocity going back to that statement
we had about being human they want you
to recognize that you're in a
relationship you're in a human
relationship if you can't satisfy these
four
i tyria here it is very hard to disrupt
because you haven't banked the goodwill
that allows disruption to have fertile
enough ground to take seed in flour it
was one of my favorites brand matters
more how is social media disrupting or
adding to brand we've talked a lot about
the second screen experience and how
happy TV producers are that social media
came along because it's giving the
entire new way to deepen the
relationship and get people to watch
more TV but the real answer is far more
insidious this is a little coca-cola
graphic we sort of carved up for a
reason because I think what's happening
is when I share wired content with my
friend Myles nadao in this equation my
brand as the sharer
means more than the Wired brand in that
social contract by the time he consumes
the content he may have actually
forgotten that it's wired he just
remembers that it came from me
algorithmics environments like Google
and Facebook or rinsing off a lot of the
brand and to exacerbate this your own
content is brand is 9 times less
important than a stranger's opinion so
what happened is we are ultimately
sharing our brand equity and if you
don't lean into this heavily most brands
are seeing real erosion a study that we
just did said that the average brand is
worth 20% less today than it was 10
years ago I think which is a really
really spooky thought if you are into
brand marketing and so where does that
leave us
P&G just announced recently I think one
of the best marketing goals I've ever
heard they said it's not about brands we
want to create a one-to-one relationship
with every customer in the world and
when you think about social media for
the first time we start to think how
that's possible have that scalable
throughout the touchpoints across my
customer
journey and I would advise all of you
who are in marketing when you go back
and you restate your marketing objective
to put that out there this is how
disruption happens they're talking about
a Nike earlier how we create goals that
don't seem possible right but if you set
they're out there we're finding that
there's paths and ways to easily get
there the primary benefit is social
media we've often reduced social media
if you look at a traditional marketing
funnel to the top of the funnel it's
awareness it's that buzz at the top well
we actually believe is that social media
has transformed that traditional
marketing funnel into a marketing glue
and here's what this means a link is the
most ubiquitous form of word-of-mouth
and is the number one way that we learn
to pay attention to marketing messages
every day people send me links on
Facebook or Twitter and email and you
know they're curating my day I can't
even keep up with all of those links
that they send me that's how you get my
attention in a digital environment
consideration is only always a click
away right so awareness is manufactured
instantly in the exchange of the link
acquisition will increasingly hop happen
at the point of emotional engagement
regardless of environment so don't have
to get you in the store I don't have to
get you to the website eventually you're
gonna be able to make everything
transaxle there's nothing I can't do in
a video that I can do on a website they
they offer the same functionality to me
now once I create a relationship with
you right and I arm you with the right
links and the right content you become
into repeat purchase you become an
advocate and this marketing loop grows
and circles right but everybody's
spending all the money in that
consideration and acquisition phase when
all the sales are coming here through
word-of-mouth so what it's asking us to
do is reconfigure our marketing mix away
from big brand awareness campaign the
smaller influencer advocacy campaign
that more reflects the loop and this
path to purchase this is the reality of
how shoppers buy
great study that I leaned on is the
average consumer goes through ten point
four touch points or media before their
point of purchase right it's a really
distributed landscape that we're going
which brings us to what's happened to
the customer journey Forrester just came
out with there was a report that said
the website is now the center of the
customer journey not the 30-second TV
spot well I think they've only gone half
the way this is what a customer journey
looks like it's completely a linear
right is it we don't know the zero
moment of truth we don't know what the
impetus is we know that you go on this
customer journey and in a word it is
social and so what it's asking brands to
do is think of that word-of-mouth at the
center of everything that they do and
socialize every bit of the customer
journey so why on earth am I seeing TV
commercials that have no URLs why am I
seeing websites that have no contextual
testimonial videos when I'm on a page
how are you getting me through those
10.4 customer touch points and how are
you realizing that our attention span is
actually shrunk in 10 years from 14
minutes that we pay attention to media
to for today so this is fundamentally
changing everything that we're doing
marketing social media doesn't drive
measurable sales when we talked about
directly how it or indirectly it does
but we also know that if anyone watched
the word Moneyball there is a Moneyball
the quants are taking over the world
the math is trumping the art because you
can measure campaigns in real time
through something called influencer
influences an algorithm of virality when
I speak how far does it travel
popularity how much exposure to have or
Authority how many engagements I have if
I triangulate that and I know how to do
it I can actually optimize creative and
campaigns in real time to change my
merchandising and if I want to know my
brand health if I want to know how my
movies gonna perform if I'm looking at
this one
metric of influence we have found it to
be the best predictor of sales and so if
you're not looking at influence I would
strongly urge you to start to really
look at that great creative drives
disruption a lot of people think the big
idea does it most big ideas are a tight
bell curve right they come they go they
don't sustain we waste a lot of money it
results in buzz and word-of-mouth my
apologies to your creative director but
again science and math are trumping art
word-of-mouth drives great creative days
of Don Draper overs for my favorite
episodes if anybody saw it around the
carousel those moments are harder
because we can now use data to inform
that creative process social media is
the world's big focus group it's all
about word-of-mouth the link is
word-of-mouth traffic is word-of-mouth
and data will drive those creative
decisions and what it means for us is we
can't conceive of creative anymore
outside of the context of how something
is consumed and shared as a link if you
run an organization where creative is
over here and the people that do the PR
or do the media planning or over here
right it can't work because that
creative ultimately needs to be
translated into a link and lastly what I
want to talk to you about is your
organization and your structure are you
ready for this change most organizations
are not ready because your organizations
are still siloed into marketing and
digital and PR and advertising and the
consumer doesn't care about paid own and
our media's
they're just part of the customer
journey they're reacting to how
compelling the media is the best model
we've found is actually to organize your
organization like a social network works
so you have the idea in the middle you
know again why share why engage why this
brand and then you replicate the
different functions around that
word-of-mouth so by the time you've gone
to layer in what channels are there
right and you've gotten to the media
you've started in a much more organic
place built around how the consume
interacting with media not how your
traditional marketing organization
starts
lastly I'll leave you with this I love
this study every year that comes out
that correlates social media performance
to share price when I first read it like
my goodness I'm gonna buy a huge yacht
because I'm moving share price to my
social media marketing I looked at the
data under more sober terms and I
realized that the companies were
listening engaging and using social data
as a real-time feedback loop we're
running better business wasn't rocket
science listen your customer that's the
opportunity of social media we don't
have a lot of time but I think we have a
chance for one maybe two questions if
anybody has any questions of social
media what it can and can't do but we
hope we could at least illuminate a
little bit about the rule what's having
in marketing
so any questions okay over the last
number of years there's been huge change
in social media and the adoption of the
use of social media and marketing by
brand marketers mmm-hmm
what's the most profound change in the
last 12 months of how marketers use
social media and what do you see
happening over the next 12 months in
terms of how that adoption will modify
their behavior I think if everybody goes
and watch is right now what JC P or JC
Penney is doing right we're what they've
done is they've created a very tight
brand promise which we've always done
then they figured out the rhythm and the
cadence and the behavior of their
customer online then they created a
narrative right so that their structure
and an experience at the center that
goes into a calendar which they actually
share with the audience and then they
socialize that calendar so what they've
done is they've created a system that
places word-of-mouth at the center of
under the brand promise for how they
execute that and again their use of
social data to inform that other that
whole process from the brand process to
how Mike
campaigns are performing to what people
like about being what they don't
it's that holistic use of social data
that's really starting to rise that you
can set up a dashboard that can mine
social media for purchase intent it's
the data it's the quants that are taking
over the world
final question or I think we're gonna
kind of wrap at that point but thank you
everybody I appreciate it